partout au pays des canadiens en
instance de parrainage se sont vêtus de
rouge rouge la couleur de l'amour mais
aussi de la colère je me sens trahi par
mon pays
marc paquette s'est marié en octobre
2019 après que son épouse a essuyé
plusieurs refus de droit de visite
il envoie une demande de parrainage
juste avant lakovic 19
mais pour d'autres manifestants à
montréal ce processus dure depuis des
années
emmanuel bergeron à une enfant de 22
mois dont le père prend la forme d'un
téléphone autant que je suis en colère
quand le gouvernement comme et refuser
le droit d'avoir mon père aime écouter
perché autant que jan koller racontent
eux de l'empêcher vivre ensemble la
pandémie a engendré des retards
importants dans le traitement des
demandes d'immigration sur son site
l'agencé fédérale dit ne pas être en
mesure de fournir des délais exactes aux
familles les manifestants exhorte le
gouvernement d'agir en accordant des
visas temporaires spéciaux à leurs
conjoints vivant à l'étranger jusqu'au
traitement de leurs demandes
une demande de tout à fait valable pour
cet avocat
les personnes quand ils viennent ici
comme visiteurs peu importe son séjour
temporaire ils doivent de toute façon
établir qu'ils ont plein de dossiers
criminels doivent établir des critères
et qui répondent à notre loi
d'immigration
donc pourquoi ne pas les laisser entrer
faire en sorte que le kop soient réunies
soit ensemble et pendant ce temps long
on finalise la demande tout simplement
ce mouvement pancanadien demande
également de restreindre les pouvoirs
des agents d'immigration
qu'ils cessent les refus sous prétexte
que les demandeurs tente de rester au
pays
au delà de leur séjour temporaire ce
règlement a brisé des vies 10 les
manifestants ils attendent toujours une
réponse d'ottawa demeuré silencieux
jusqu'à présent ici marie josée paquet
comme radio canada montréal